everyone this is kevin from
thechestwebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over a really easy
trap in the perk defense that's going to
allow you to get some easy
easy wins so perk defense usually starts
out white playing e4 and then black
playing something like d6 and then d4
trying to control the center of the
board followed by knight to f6
knight to c3 and then pawn g6 preparing
to get fion kiddo the bishop here to g7
and you can see there's a lot of pieces
trying to defend and attack this e5
central square now usually white's going
to play either f4
you can see that's attacking this e5
square or even f3 both of those are
attacking the e5 square i think a really
fun way to play is bring out the dark
square bishop here to f4 and that's
where our trap is going to start from
adding another piece
to this e5 square but also attacking the
entire dark square diagonal here black
usually for all of those variations we
looked at usually plays bishop to g7
counter attack the dark squares in the
center of the board and then white's
going to be playing pawn to e5 saying
yes you your fiance your bishop to
castle on the king side get some safety
before you have time to do that we want
to attack right away
now the best move from black in this
position is to play knight to h5
attacking the bishop on f4 since it's
under attack this gets the knight out of
harm's way and attacks the piece here on
f4
but also pretty common for them just to
take on e5 i think you're gonna see that
more often than not and after the pawn
takes then queen comes down exchanges on
a d1 and after rook to d1 this is where
we start to see the trap unfold
because where does black move from here
one of the most common things that
you'll see from black is to play the
move knight to d7 and we'll look at what
happens if they play something else
maybe like knight two g4 as well but you
can see there's rook on d1 controlling
this d file so knight to d7
makes a lot of sense the knight center
attack needs to move that and so this
looks like it's blocking off some of the
threats that white has
with the rook here on at d1 but this
loses to the move knight to d5 and this
is what we're going to be talking about
in the video because they have fallen
for the trap and it's pretty basic moves
from black they didn't have to do
anything crazy
and even if they don't fall for it
white's going to have a pretty good and
solid position still controlling the
center of the board so after knight to
d5 really the threat is the knight
coming here to
c7 now one of the ways that black would
usually hold on to this pawn on c7 is to
play the move knight to a6
but they can't do that because we can
just take with our bishop here on a six
and after they capture we're going to
play knight c7 and this is forking the
rook here on a8 now if we come back this
is the reason we play knight d5 instead
of knight to b5 if we play knight to b5
that's not actually going to work
because they can play knight a6
defending this pawn and now our bishop
here on f1 cannot take that knight on a6
and so this would be a poor move from
white so instead we do play the correct
move because we watched the video knight
d5 attacking the pawn
and so now how does black respond from
here
they have some huge mistakes they can
make you know knight takes here on
e5 just completely ignoring the threats
here this is even worse than something
else they could do because now we have
the threat of not just forking the rook
here uh but you can see the king can't
move to uh d8 here or d7 because of the
rook uh the bishop can't even come block
anything else because of the knights
being uh the one doing the attacking so
king to f8 and then we have rook to d8
that's going to be checkmate so they
definitely have some really awful moves
let's look at the not as awful moves
they could see the the fort coming and
so king castles on the king side okay
well we can just take here on c7 and
then we're going to capture
that rook here on a8 now they could try
some different stuff now let's say
knight to
b6 this is defending the rook here on a8
which we can still capture if we want to
but we can also just play bishop to e3
and that stops everything they were
trying to do because now we can just
take this knight and then there's no way
for them to stop us taking the rook here
on
a 8. from here they could try
knight 2 c6 trying to open things up so
the rook here on f8 can defend that but
then we're just going to take with our
bishop
and then this does open up for the rook
to swing over to b8
but now our bishop can come c5 and yes
we did not capture the rook but we did
get a free piece here on
b6 and now we still have a very very
dominant position we still have a knight
that's putting a lot of pressure on
black we have a very active bishop here
on c5 we can get our light square bishop
uh involved into the game we can also
get our rook involved into the game so
this is going to be a pretty easy end
game for
white now if we come back
let's say instead of castling on the
king side they say okay if you're
attacking the pawn on c7 let's just go
ahead and play king to d8 that stops the
immediate threat here and that is true
but now white has the move pawn e6 and
you can see that's one of the reasons
that i like bishop on f4
is it allows us to attack this bishop or
this pawn here on c7 with our bishop and
our knight see both of those pieces
lined up on this pawn and so how do they
stop it from here okay first they attack
and take with their own pawn
attacking our knight that's fine we were
always going to be taking with our
knight on c7 this is again attacking the
rook on a8
maybe they play pawn
e6 or e5 excuse me attacking the bishop
here on f4 okay that's fine because now
we can bring our knight back to e6
attacking the king check king comes to
e8 now we take the bishop on g7 you can
see we're just gobbling out material the
king is no longer going to be safe the
rest of the game for black king can come
to f7 but then bishop h6 holding down
this knight and white's going to have a
pretty easy game from here on out
looked at the knight coming to d7 but if
they were to play knight to g4 this
would also be a mistake here trying to
get the knight out of harm's way but we
still have the move knight to d5
attacking this pawn on c7 so you know if
they castle on the king side we're just
gonna take here on c7 and easily capture
the rook on a8 the slight difference
that you could see is if they were to
play king d8
trying to hold down this pawn on c7
they've put themselves in a
tough position because we have a very
very powerful discovered check because
after the knight moves anywhere then
we're checking our opponent's king and
then we have free reign to just gobble
up some pieces with you know the most
obvious being knight 2 f6 this is check
king is under attack so maybe knight d7
blocking that but then we can just swing
down and take this knight on
g4
so that is the way that i like to attack
the perk defense really some easy wins
that you'll see in this
so remember after you have your normal
setup instead of playing your f4 or
knight to f3
some typical ways that you may play
against the perk defense try out bishop
here to f4 and after they play bishop g7
push forward e5 and just see how many
times they fall for the trap i think
it's going to be more than you would
expect so hopefully you guys enjoyed the
video excited to be making a lot more
content for you if you have any
suggestions for videos you want me to
make this year let me know in the
comments below thank you guys and i'll
see you in the next video
you